[Music]
[Music]
and 72 late Millie became the associate
department head in CCS and since then
before then and since then has had a
very illustrious career in in research
in science at one time Millie gets about
10 years ago was president of the
American Physical Society
she's an institute professor and has
appointments in both the Department of
Physics in the Department of Electrical
Engineering she won the national medal
of science back in 1990 Dobby the
highest award that the country u.s. can
give to one of its scientists she's a
recipient of over over a 17 honorary
degrees
recently in 1999 she received an
honorary degree from the universe from
the Sorbonne in Paris and turned out
that she's the first woman to have
received an honorary degree in the
sciences from the Sorbonne in this year
just last week she received an honorary
degree from the University of Leuven in
Belgium and next week we'll be giving
the Celsius lectures in at the
University of Uppsala in Sweden as I say
mili has a very illustrious and long a
list of honours and if I went through
all of them I'd take up half of her time
I think you really want to hear familiy
I'm very honored to be the first one
again I did the first in the EECS series
about a year or a year and a half ago
and so this auspicious beginning as we
all say my topic today is very different
from last time this time I'm talking
about
bismuth nanowires and I could give
almost the same topic title as I gave
last time what which was the remarkable
properties structure and properties of
carbon nanotubes that's the last one I
did in EECS colloquium but I was a
little bit more modest because the
bismuth nano wires are a lot newer and
maybe we don't know exactly all the
remarkable properties about them yet
well I have a few collaborators actually
worldwide and a lot of graduate students
and three of them have already gotten
their PhDs related to this topic so good
subject for training students now in in
light of the invitation I thought I
would focus my remarks about nano
structures before I start talking about
bismuth those of you who listen to the
president's State of the Union speech he
didn't have a lot to say about science
but he did have something to say about
nano wire nano structures and so nano
wires are part of nano structures so I'd
like to call your attention to the
importance of this and in my first view
graph I'm trying to give you the scale
of what a nano structure is and so here
we have a plot and we have a plot of
different things on a scale so you see
that the x axis here gives a size and
there's a line here that's at about 57
a nanometer something like that and
anything below that begins to show
quantum effects and with quantum effects
it's not that we're just making things
smaller and smaller to get a higher
packing ratio of whatever component it
is like we're doing silicon technology
the first thought is to pack our our
devices smaller and smaller so you get a
higher packing density but when you do
this you also get new physics that comes
in that it allows you to do new things
and it's the second point of view that
I'd like to stress in my talk today so
you see here on this picture there are a
lot of different things GMR giant
magnetoresistance quantum dots and
lasers nanotubes carbon nanotubes which
I talked about my last EECS colloquium
etc and bismuth nano wires spanned the
scale moving in to the Nano structure
regime where quantum effects are
important my second view graph of what
of a general nature about nano
structures tells you in simple terms
why nano structures are important and
interesting why anybody cares about them
why President Clinton said that this is
something that we should be thinking
about and working on why is that well
when we have bulk semiconductors as we
know when we love in the industry what
we basically have is this situation
shown on top where the density of states
that is the number of states per energy
range is essentially continuous that is
we have a contested structure that's
really quite large compared to the
quantum of regime limit on the other end
of the scale here quantum dot label
quantum dot where we might have a single
atom or a molecule we have discrete
States and somewhere in between we have
one-dimensional systems like here we
have the quantum wire or in this case we
have the quantum
which is a two-dimensional system and
you will see that the density of states
that is the number of states per energy
range is distinctly different and the
smaller the size or the smaller
dimension that we're dealing with the
more the system becomes like a molecule
with these discrete states now when we
are in the regime of the discrete States
we have new phenomenon and that's the
kind of thing that I'm going to
emphasize in my discussion of the
bismuth nanowires where we're interested
in going to smaller and smaller sizes
where the system shows quantum effects
that phenomenon that are not present in
the bulk now I'd like to tell you how I
got into the business nanowire business
and this was motivated by practical
considerations one of the nice things
about being in an engineering department
is we have a push and pull between the
practical and the science-based studies
so my initial motivation for this came
from a practical driver and this is
interest in making thermal electrics
that are better than present thermal
electrics thermal electrics have two
applications one is for cooling purposes
and the other is for energy conversion
at high temperature and here is a
picture a diagram of the thermoelectric
figure of Merit for our present
discussion this is a particularly
important except to say that the state
of the art has a value of this quantity
figure of Merit ZT dimensionless
quantity of 1 and it's
been at this value since approximately
nineteen sixty if thermoelectrics could
have their figure of merit increase to a
factor of three they could be
competitive to a refrigerator something
that we know and it would change the
economics and interest in this kind of
applications area enormous lee however
nobody has figured out how to do this
and not for lack of effort but lack of
ideas we had an idea about how to change
this a few years ago by going to low
dimensions and you could see this
picture is sort of a visionary picture
and it said if you could make a
one-dimensional bismuth or
two-dimensional for that matter we could
exceed the ZT of one with small sizes of
either a quantum well of bismuth or a
quantum wire of bismuth and in fact get
values that are phenomenally bigger than
even what you could do with a
refrigerator however there's a long way
to go from the actuality and this
phantom dream the material the actual
material that might do this would be
this bismuth that i mentioned which has
some astounding properties of all
materials it has a constant energy
surface we call this a Fermi surface
that is more anisotropic than any other
material and I sought repeat in the
Fermi surface is very very desirable for
thermal electricity as is multiple
carrier pockets which is another feature
of bismuth bismuth also has a very high
mobility which is another promising
feature for thermal electrics and
because it is a very heavy atom it has a
very low thermal conductivity and for
all of these reasons this should be the
ideal material to be used for a
thermoelectric
however the problem with bismuth and the
reason why bismuth has never succeeded
as a thermoelectric has to do with the
following point property bismuth is a
semi metal with an equal number of
electrons and holes so that the top of
the valence band top of the valence band
shown here is higher in energy than the
bottom of the conduction band so it's a
sort of a semi conductor with a never
negative bandgap so you always have both
electrons and holes present and for
thermoelectricity the contribution of
the electrons essentially cancels that
of the holes and it is a very poor
thermal thermoelectric material for that
reason however if you could figure out
some way to make this material either
totally n-type or totally p-type and for
thermal electric you have to be able to
do both then this could be very very
interesting so here's the idea and this
is an idea that we had simultaneously
almost with the idea of the going doing
through low therm low dimensional
thermoelectrics what I have shown on
this picture here is the sub band
structure or the first sub band for
electrons related to the band edge for
the bulk and the first sub band which is
below the band edge for the holes as
shown on the left your left hand side so
now as the size of the quantum well or
the quantum wire decreases the
difference in energy between the first
sub band and the band edge increases so
this sub bad edge will move up and for
the holes this sub n edge will move down
and eventually at some value of the size
of your quantum well or your quantum
wire
a semiconductor will be formed and once
you have a semiconductor you can make
that either in or p-type so that was the
initial motivation of a studying bismuth
and we talked somebody into giving us
some money to do this so we started work
on this project but an idea was
necessary because it isn't easy to make
any low dimensional structures with
bismuth because bismuth diffuses into
every almost everything so we had to
devise some mechanism to have confined
quantum confined system and the idea
came through a public service activity
for Jacky yang whose collaborator on
this project and she invited me to tell
chemical engineers about carbon
nanotubes and while they were listening
to me tell them about carbon nanotubes I
thought I should listen to them tell me
about catalysis so I listened to a
lecture and heard about molecular sibs
and my cells that will self orient this
is used in the oil recovery business
they have of course no interest in
making low dimensional semiconductors
but in listening to them I had the idea
what they do is make self-organized
holes in a template so they make
something that looks like this and when
I saw this I said voila this is exactly
what we need for low dimensional
thermoelectrics and many other
scientific applications so we start out
here with an aluminium film and so
that's like aluminum foil it's a little
bit maybe higher purity and we polish
the surface etc anodized this
electrochemically and there's a
competing mechanism that forms these
holes and depending on the acid that's
used for the electrochemical treatment
the length of time of the voltage
current
missions you can control the size of the
pores etc so these pores are made and
then we use another acid to take off the
bottom and high pressure to fill the
channels that are formed eventually with
fluids in this case bismuth but you can
put in magnetic fluids something goes
superconducting many many possibilities
and for some applications we would like
to measure individual wires so we
dissolve this template we have
individual wires to make four probe
measurements on individual wires
that's where Hank Smith's help has come
in so Jacky yang taught us how to make
these templates and helped us with the
filling of the templates and we had a
lot of help from Professor Smith this
kind introduction but he's done more
than that he's helped us to fill the to
make transport measurements our earliest
work was done this is our first attempt
and you see here first student so these
wires are a little bit on the large side
65 nanometers just at the junction of
being called nano structures and so
looking down top on you could see these
cylinders they're not so perfect but the
length to diameter ratio is about a
thousand thousand aspect so they're long
skinny things and the density of wires
here was approximately 10 to the tenth
wires per square centimeters we do more
than that with the smaller wires so
there are a lot of wires that are made
and I'd like to show you Ming's uming
Lin's
more recent work with improved
processing step and this is a much
smaller diameter wire and the they're
more perfect than the large ones that
the previous student
and now we're down to 80 nanometers and
these aren't so bad and we have ideas
for improving them further so the
technology is challenging to us but we
are electrical engineering students seem
to be able to handle this and make
progress with it when we take the
templates dissolve the templates you see
here the freestanding wires they're very
long and skinny and with high resolution
TEM you could see that they're fairly
straight and this these striations show
grain boundary structures not very many
grain boundaries but some grain
boundaries and the size of these grain
boundaries is about the diameter of the
of the tubes so this is something that
we're very interested in now the nano
wires would be of relatively little use
were it not for this great property that
they have that the Nano dental wires are
single crystals with common axis along
the wires so a given wire will have a
common axis but all the wires in the
array the 10 to the 10th or so wires
will have the same common axis most of
them a large a high percentage and you
can see this as the x-ray diffraction
pattern with very sharp lines so it
looks like a single crystal now what we
found recently in our first work we were
making bigger size wires and all the
wires had the orientation 101 and we
thought that they'd all come out that
way but as the wire diameters got
smaller we have a new preferred
orientation that goes from 48 and down
to about 20 and we haven't really done
much characterization below that length
but we suspect that there are also
single crystals so this is of important
property why is it important
all the wires are the same so they have
a common property so we can characterize
them and because of this we're able to
have very long mean fret mean free paths
we have a property that's called
ballistic transport that I'll describe
in a little bit that says that the wire
that the electrons will move for very
long distances before being scattered
for distances that are much longer than
the wire diameters so that's an
important consideration another thing
that I should mention about this that
makes this property quite remarkable is
that the crystal structure that is these
diffraction Peaks are at exactly at the
same places same angles as they are in
bulk bismuth so we have basically both
bismuth that's put in the wires so
almost everything that we know about
both bismuth also applies to the nano
wires this was unexpected lovely
property for these nano wires now other
people have tried to make nano wires
before of this sort but this was the
first successful attempt in making
single crystal nano wires certainly of
bismuth now how do we know that they're
all the same
well we have an x-ray diffraction
pattern which gives you the diffraction
pattern of many many nano wires and then
we have an electron diffraction pattern
for single selected nano wires and so
from this pattern we can tell what the
orientation happens to be and that
orientation is the same as for the x-ray
diffraction so we know that not only do
we have single crystals but they're all
the same close to all the same obviously
there's some deviation you never have
perfection and in a project like this
the Raman spectra is also interesting
and I show on top the Raman spectra for
both bismuth and because it's such a
heavy atom the vibrational modes are at
very low frequency and when we make the
nano wires you'll see
that the same frequencies are appear so
we have the same mode structure but the
relative intensities are different and
this is an area that we hope to be
studying in the near future so to
summarize about the remarkable structure
of the nanowires so here's the structure
structural properties we have a narrow
distribution of wire diameters less than
10% they're quite uniform along the
length again much less than 10% there
are single crystals with a common axis
along the wire but otherwise randomly
oriented in the cross-sectional area
with respect to each other not not with
respect to each one but with respect to
each other and they have the same
crystal structure as both bismuth the
material in which they're the template
material in which the bismuth nano wires
sit is a wide gap semiconductor three
and a half electron volts so we have
quantum confined electrons in the wires
they don't talk to each other so oh and
thermal conductivity is very low and a
bunch of other interesting properties
dielectric constants very high few other
interesting properties no I'm going to
talk about the unusual properties up
till now we talked about the structure
now I'm going to talk about the
properties so the first thing was the
semi metal semiconducting semiconductor
transition and just to remind you with
what that is and I hope I can find my
little view graph that showed that here
we go so this is the basic view graph
what we're looking looking at we're
looking for that diameter for the wire
where this sub band where the holes
crosses the electron highest electrons
ban for the electrons and a bandgap is
formed so that's the concept of what
we're looking for and now I'd like to
give a few examples of its observation
so we have optical properties transport
properties and several other properties
so now to get a little bit more specific
about the bismuth structure I have I
have to show you bismuth is a
complicated material and if it weren't
complicated most of the things I'm
talking about wouldn't it would not
happen so we have the L point electron
so these are the electron the L point
electrons and there are multiple carrier
pockets which will have the same energy
in the bulk material but once we make
nano wires out of them then we have a
splitting in energy between them and
that complicates our thinking about the
problem but for this audience and the
simple picture will neglect that for the
most part and here are the holes and if
we didn't have the crystal rhombohedral
crystal symmetry and this were cubic the
t-point holes and the T and L point
would be all the same and we wouldn't
have a semi metal so that the special
properties of bismuth that allow us to
make a semiconductor out of it by going
to low dimensions all right bound up are
closely connected with the fact that
bismuth is anisotropic ok so this is
important consideration I'll return to
this at some point
and now just I'd like to mention about
the semi conductor semi semi metal
semiconductor transition so here's our
picture for the semi mettlesome
conductor transition at at large values
of the wire diameter then we have we the
separation that we're talking about here
would be the bad overlap of bismuth
which is about 40 millivolts what's
shown here for the direction that the
wires actually grow we have a and the
eight point pockets that are along this
cross-section which is the mirror plane
of the reciprocal lattice zone this
carrier pocket is different from the B
and C the details of that are not
terribly important for our present
discussion in the limit that the wires
are very large then these two lines
become equal to each other and we have a
common value for this band overlap as
the wire dimension gets smaller we get a
splitting and this shows the splitting
that makes the a and B and C different
and the reason for that has to do with
the relation of the symmetry of these
carrier pockets and the growth direction
which are not along a common high
symmetry axis the important point is
that as the diameter gets smaller
eventually we get a crossover with this
whole band level this is the highest
conduction sub band for the holes and at
this point we cross this a point carrier
pocket and at this point we cross the B
and C carry a pocket and at this point
right here 15 nanometers we make the
semi metal semiconductor transition so
that's what we're talking about and what
is the evidence that we have for
observing this phenomenon
well the Fermi energy will be somewhere
between these two such that such that
the number of electrons is equal to the
number of holes okay hmm it goes right
through here if you have no dopants so
how would this be observed now the most
prosaic and simple observation is to do
an optical absorption experiment so if
you have a semiconductor then you have a
sentence parent situation very low
absorption and if you have semi metal
you'll have relatively high absorption
and that's what's shown here so this is
a very crude simple-minded picture of
what you might see and so this is a
first experiment we did so that's like a
flashlight type experiment and we're
trying now to do this much more
quantitatively and that's the thesis of
Marcie black and she's making good
progress with it so hopefully soon we'll
hear more details the transport
properties are quite interesting so here
is both bismuth so this is resistance
normalized to the room temperature value
and I'll explain a little why why we
have to do it that way so this is both
bismuth and you see when we get to the
nano wires the temperature dependence of
the resistance is very very different
from bulk bismuth and in fact these
wires down here are the semi metallic
wires while those wires up there are all
a semiconducting and the and you could
see that the behavior is very very
different and what determines a
temperature dependent resistance is
always a an interplay between the
temperature dependence of the carrier
density which for a semiconductor is
very strong and the second effect of
course is the temperature dependence of
mobility which is
important for the semi-metallic phase so
that the interplay between these and the
fact also that the properties of
semiconducting semi metal properties are
also temperature dependent is what's
responsible for this complex behavior so
these are the experiments done for a
number of nano wires and this is Yu
Ming's recent calculation for his
master's thesis and here's 17 and no
adjustable parameters here here is 70
nanometers and here are 70 nanometers
for the experiment that looks pretty
good and the 36 is shown there so this
much we are able now to explain with a
simple calculation and I'll get to that
in a moment what we do about that but
there's still details to be filled in we
don't have all the answers yet but this
is where we've what we've accomplished
thus far at low temperatures very low
temperatures where localization effects
are beginning to become important below
10 degrees localization effects become
important like in the 2 degree range but
you see here more clearly that for the
semiconducting tubes the resistance the
coefficient of resistance with
temperature is positive for the semi
metal face going up and for the
semiconducting phase it's going down and
there are no exceptions for that the
situation for the magneto resistance is
quite interesting also but more
complicated for explanation so I didn't
bring that along but it fits in with the
general picture that I've told you this
view graph shows the more complicated
situation which underlines the
temperature dependence of the properties
of the bismuth nano wires so if we are
we have a very small nano wire like a 10
nanometer diameter nano wire then
all the way from the lowest temperature
all the way to room temperature behaves
like a semiconductor in the UC for many
orders of magnitude the carrier density
is going to change this is a plot of
carrier density with an exponential
scale as a function of temperature on
the other hand if we have an 80
nanometer wire then it's always
semi-metallic independent of temperature
over this entire range and you see that
the dependence of that carrier density
in that case is very minor so this shows
you about the interplay between the
carrier density for the different kinds
of nanowires temperature and resistivity
transport properties now for an
intermediate case 40 nano nano meters at
low temperatures behaves like a semi
conductor at high temperature behaves
like a semi metal so this wire undergoes
a semiconductor semi metal a transition
as a function of temperature and we can
and that is part of the explanation that
we showed you where the temperature
dependent transport now the next
phenomenon that I'd like to talk about
is ballistic transport in these
materials
what is ballistic transport this
phenomenon occurs when the mean free
path is large compared to the size of
the sample and when that happens you can
have wave propagation
instead of particle propagation now in
our case we use a magnetic field to
demonstrate this phenomenon and I'm
going to show you how we do that so the
next view graph shows how we do
transport measurements on our nano nano
wire arrays and after I'll show you how
we do it on a single nano wire so here
we have many many nano wires we have 10
to the 10th nano
they're all lined up and we put
electrode on the top and the bottom and
we could measure either resistance or we
could measure magneto resistance
resistance in the presence of a magnetic
field we do both of those kinds of
experiments and they give us a lot of
information the information we cannot
get from this is what is the absolute
value of the resistance as a function of
temperature and the reason for that is
we don't know how many nano wires we
have in our sample that are actually
contacting the electrodes and we have no
way of measuring that at the present
time so we have to do normalize
measurements when we did when we're
working in this format the other thing
that problem is that we have some
contact resistance so that two point
measurements never give you very
accurate absolute measurements however
these kinds of measurements are fine for
measuring for looking for phenomenon
like ballistic transport so this view
graph demonstrates ballistic transport
you know in in some way so for example
the black curve is taken at a hundred
Kelvin and you just see an increasing
function of the resistance is a function
of magnetic field however when we get
down to lower temperatures you see that
there's a peak there's a maximum the
maximum has to do with the following
effect at low magnetic fields the
electrons are making large orbits so
they tend to bump into the edge of the
wire more frequently than they would
normally because the magnetic field
deflects magnetic fields along the wire
direction the magnetic field that
deflects the path of the electrons so
they intersect with the edge more
frequently and therefore they have more
scattering and therefore the resistance
goes up
ever when the magnetic field gets large
enough to start containing the electrons
to move within the wire diameter then we
have less scattering than we had before
and therefore the resistance goes down
well that's a hypothesis and now I'll
show you all the different parameters
that we try is in agreement with that
hypothesis I'll show you a few of them
but we've done quite a number of others
besides what I'm showing you here here
is the comparison for two diameters so
if you have a smaller diameter it takes
a larger magnetic field to fit the
wanted to have the orbit contained
within the wire diameter so for the
smaller diameters the critical field is
higher than for the larger diameters as
is shown here and the dependence
actually goes like one over the diameter
in the inverse diameter and we have a
nice plot of that so the the picture of
what's going on is shown in this view
graph so the for a zero field of course
you have some scattering but as you have
more the field increases a little bit
we the orbits are deflected so that
there's increased contact with the wire
so the resistance goes up but then when
the high magnetic fields are reached and
we get these circular orbits then we
miss the tenth start missing the
interaction with the boundaries and we
can see this ballistic transport effect
so now if your the magnetic field
instead of being along the wire is
transverse to the wire so we should not
see this effect at all so okay here we
are transverse magnetic field
independent of temperature they're all
approximately quadratic and with the
longitudinal field if you add some
dopants so that you make the mean free
path of the electrons the electrons
never reach the wire boundary they don't
know the wire boundary is there so then
it behaves
quadratically another very interesting
phenomenon that occurs has to do with
orbits in a magnetic field at low
temperatures in our solid state course
we talk about the magnetic length of
electrons so electrons in a magnetic
field experience the quantization of the
magnetic energy levels and the magnetic
length is given here by this relation
and this is a measure of the size of
electron wave function in a magnetic
field when the wire diameter and the
magnetic length become approximately
equal to each other so that the magnetic
lengths are shown here for the various
wires as shown on the on this picture
magnetic field corresponding to these
lengths and when that length is equal to
the wire diameter we have these these
lines and you will see on these curves
that there are kinks on the lowest one
on the top of 70 nanometer you see quite
a large kick and four fields lower than
that point where that there well I
should say that the kink occurs when one
flux unit is contained within the wire
one quantum flux unit of magnetic flux
is contained within the wire diameter
there's an effect below that effect
we have confinement because of the wire
diameter so that's a one-dimensional
effect and for higher magnetic fields we
have confinement because of the magnetic
field so the Sai ammeter the size of the
wire dimensionality the wire is not
important so we have a changeover in
effect in phenomenon and therefore
different dependences of the resistor
on magnetic field temperature and
everything else one of the drawbacks of
our measurement technique is that we can
don't know how many wires we make
contact with so we have to do some kind
of measurements too on single wires and
Hank has helped us with his little
liftoff technique to allow us to make
contacts with individual wires so here
is an individual wire and there are a
lot of processing steps that you see we
have a grid that's defined
photolithography
by actually by an electron beam so we
have a lot of points here and we use
these points to locate where a given
wire is so here's a given wire and the
wire position relative to some fiducial
marks is noted and then we apply photo
lithographic techniques to put leads are
attach leads to this wire and we have a
liftoff technique that finally provides
us with four contacts two of which are
shown here but we actually put four
contacts on the sample and the resulting
picture is shown here the four contacts
are the this cross gives you the four
contacts and their contact to big pads
and then we can do experiments related
to the big pads but inside the middle of
of this is the actual wire assembly
that's shown here so here's our bismuth
nano wire and here are the four contact
points so this allows us to do voltage
current measurement so we are at the
earliest possible stages with this but
we have our first results showing that
the absolute resistivity here to this
current voltage diagram from the slope
you can get the resistivity and the
resistivity is
what larger than that of both bismuth
factor of six showing a reduction in the
mobility of the carriers due to boundary
scattering and probably other defects
now we have a big program ahead of us to
measure this all as a function of
temperature and wire diameter so this
will keep us busy for many months I
would like now to say something about
how we go about research in this field
and this is kind of work almost getting
to concluding remarks when we get when
we or any other group starts working in
low dimensional devices and physics
modeling becomes a very very important
part of the exercise without modeling we
never can make a device that will
satisfy our imagination for
specifications because in something like
thermoelectricity but it could be almost
anything else it's very easy to make
your device worse than the
three-dimensional device and only by
very careful selection of how to make
the design of the device will you
actually be better than you are in the
three-dimensional system so I'd like to
emphasize the importance of the concept
of modeling and then the use of modeling
to actually actually determine the
design parameters to get a useful device
so this is kind of a new way of doing
device design I know this is true and
all the other groups working with nano
structures this is a different way of
looking at things and I'll just make a
couple of comments about the situation
in bismuth and then I'll talk about fine
some final comments about doping the
samples and that we we think we know how
to do it but it's a very challenging
thing to do that for bismuth nano ours
when you start moving into a new area in
a new field and the great unknowns there
are many issues
have not been previously addressed by
any investigator so you have to be
careful that you get it right
well the bismuth is a complicated system
because we have holes holes are pretty
easy it's just a diagonal tensile like
like you know for common semiconductors
but the electrons are much more
complicated the constant energy surfaces
there are numerous there are three of
them they're different from each other
and there are the very elongated
ellipsoids not along high symmetry
directions but they're tilted from the
high symmetry directions the other thing
is that the bandgap is so small that
they couples closely to each other so we
cannot use a simple parabolic model that
we use for holes but we have to have
coupled bad models so that the
calculation becomes quite complex in a
hurry so now we have made some we have
some remarkably good students at MIT in
in concept solving these equations is
not as straightforward the
implementation is not straightforward
so you Ming Lin has just finished his
master's thesis and figured out a very
nice numerical solution for the churning
equation for the case of an isotropic
surfaces multiple carrier pockets and a
strongly coupled bands and it's based on
this grid structure which allows us to
do a difference equation and numerical
solution and the results have been very
interesting and this is the first time
we've been able to get quantitative
agreement with the experiments as I
showed you before
the next thing that has to be done to
make a device is to control the doping
both N and p-type the doping of n-type
is the one we start at first because
that one is easier in the case of
bismuth the doping of p-type is more
complicated reasons I might explain and
so first success was obtained quickly
so on the top you see pure bismuth and
that and then the conductivity increases
by a couple of orders magnitude when you
dope it so you could see that you could
change the properties by doping bismuth
is calling five of the periodic table
doping with an element in column six
gives you electrons and type doping with
an element in column four it should give
you p-type and it sort of does except
for complications so we can tweak and of
our system and the next view graph shows
that we can change the electrical
properties so here's the temperature
dependence of the normalized resistance
for a different top picture top curve is
four undoped and you see different
doping concentrations and you could see
that the resistance changes and we have
from our model we can predict what the
what the effect of carrier concentration
is we know how much dope it we've added
we can imagine where we are on this
curve and then from that back out what
the temperature dependence of the
mobility is and the results here turned
out to be far better than I would ever
have expected we have a model here for
the contribution from electron phonon
interaction which is the uhnope case
from defects
that's impurities that are isoelectronic
impurities that are present or other
defects and then our charge scattered
scatterers and using just the simple
model and the different temperature
regimes were able to get the correct
temperature dependence for each of these
phenomenon each of these processes and
so this was beyond my expectation I was
I'm very proud of you Ming's result on
this because this was better than I had
expected at our present stage in this
problem the problem of doing the Pete
type doping p-type doping it's
complicated by the following physical
phenomenon doping with p-type is very
much controlled by the the p-type
carriers that we have in the intrinsic
solid due to these T point holes and
trying to lower the Fermi level by
adding p-type impurities is greatly
hampered by having this large reservoir
of holes and what we are hoping to do is
a new optimization approach this is work
for the future is by adding a small
amount of antimony we hope to make some
kind of revolution on the band structure
of bismuth we have a way of moving the
t-point holes which are over here to
lower energies and try to get them out
of the way of the carriers that we would
add by doping we figured that a few
percent of antimony should be sufficient
to make a real difference and to get
some good p-type dopant for device
applications where we need both can and
p-type materials finally this project is
is somewhat driven we always have behind
us our masters who are supporting this
research and this is to try to make a
good thermoelectric the metal insulator
transition that is the semi metal
semiconductor transition occurs at about
40 to 50 nanometers that's a very very
big size as interesting science to be
done there and we're working away at
that because that's necessary to go the
next step but our calculations from our
band models show us that the interesting
device applications occur at very much
smaller sizes to get Z T that is the
thermoelectric figure of Merit to be
greater
than one we have to have our n-type
samples to be on the order of 10
nanometers so that's a big challenge but
an even bigger challenge is our pea
types samples have to be smaller than
about five nanometers unless we're smart
and our idea with the antimony doping
works so we have a hard master here
that's moving us to improve our
technology in making and characterizing
our samples and forcing us to
understanding our system in great detail
so we can make some realistic
predictions for this small size in the
meantime we're spending quite a bit of
effort in under trying to understand the
science of the semi metal semiconductor
transition and then studying the
properties of this material which in
nature doesn't occur as a semiconductor
but at low dimensions like nano wires it
does and it's a remarkable new kind of
semiconductor that has very different
features from other semiconductors in
terms of the carrier pockets their
orientations the very high mobilities
that are possible here ballistic
transport and many other phenomena we're
looking forward to having some unusual
optical properties because of the close
coupling between the conduction and
valence band we expect a high dielectric
constants and that might be interesting
for a whole band of other applications
because there aren't that many
semiconductors around with very high
dielectric constants so I will end my my
talk at this point we've started a new
area and a lot of people are looking at
different aspects of this in terms of
nano structural science the fact that we
have templates has attracted a lot of
people into template use for putting a
lot of other materials inside the pores
whether they're
materials or superconductors or what
have you
there interesting things to be done with
this new category of materials and we
continue while also plugging away at the
thermal electrics because those are our
masters at the moment thank you okay do
we have some questions yes a lot of
details are not quite in place yet and I
would say that for example I showed you
the temperature dependence of the
resistivity we can't fit everything in
detail but we get that we have the
general features locked out now and we
have to add well for example our models
are very crude we have a constant
relaxation time approximation we use
that frequently and in doing our
modeling that obviously is not
sufficient we should take into account
the actual scattering processes for
phonons not down to the sizes that we
have studied up to this point I'm very
interested there are people at MIT that
promise us that they could make us some
smaller nanowires
smaller than four at nanometers in
diameter and smaller and I believe at
some point they by the way but Wendy
okay has a method and I hope it works we
don't know yet but that that's one of
the virtues of the that being in a large
research university with a lot of smart
people you get help they listen to your
what you're doing they have ideas about
some aspect that interests them as well
and I believe that there's going to be
some diameter where we have a phase
transition and we don't have bismuth we
as we know it it's it has a different
crystal structure from both
bismuth and then we're gonna have
nanowires with some unknown properties
maybe very interesting but certainly
different and we're looking very hard to
find out what happens in that regime
that's qualitatively different from what
we're doing now and we have no idea
where that will occur but we know down
to seven nanometers it hasn't happened
because we have measurements of
transport properties down to seven
nanometers diameter and that still is
like both bismuth no business has this
very long mean free path I mean how how
long is it it that's a it's millimeters
long and why is that
but why is it longer than say in a
modulation doped semiconductor why is it
longer than and I'm much longer
or does it magnitude longer like say in
in a you know usual well the main three
pads are several micro okay.you microns
well let me sort of explain about
bismuth and let Telluride has some of
the same properties if you have a
material with a very large dielectric
constant it the carries a sort of self
shielded by their the fact that you have
a a dielectric constant of 100 or so and
I think that that is a large part of you
you have impurities present mmm-hmm but
it the effect of impurities is greatly
reduced by screening effects due to long
me high dielectric constant okay that's
one answer to it but of course when you
have the quantum wires that we have here
the mean free path decreases yeah it's
not larger than the size of the nanowar
yeah okay any other questions yes
the reason for going for a semiconductor
is we want a single carry yeah that's
right you you have a whole range of
phenomena where electrons and holes are
cancels ABEC effect is one of them and
yes the the the the the bandgap can get
quite large it can get a more than 100
millivolts you could you can arrange
this that that's what we're trying to do
now is to arrange we would like to use
this as a 77k for device applications I
think it fits bismuth better than room
temperature although I think we probably
could make a device higher in
temperature than 77 but the first thing
that we're trying to do is 77 K because
we know a lot about the energy bands at
77 K at higher temperatures they start
to get temperature dependent and the
data for the dependence of all
parameters on temperature is very poor
so we have a lot of research to be done
just to find out what people normally
know about semiconductors in this yes
Caroline yes
okay electro deposition electro
deposition is one of the things that we
hope to try electro deposition has
certain virtues
in that the wire at the beginning and
the end is defined so that you can make
contact to all wires that you have so
that's a very big plus
up till now there has been some work
done on electro deposition of bismuth
nano wires the problem is that the mean
free paths of those nano wires is rather
short and they cannot see ballistic
transport the way we do it with our nano
wires that is they have many many grains
along the length of a single manner wire
well we have relatively few grades we
have some ideas about how to make once
we get a nano wire in our template we
have ideas how we can make the grain
size very much larger so it's similar to
what we have in the pressure preparation
this has not been this is only up here
with me and my students in such a
talking stage but I hope that within a
year or so we'll be able to demonstrate
some of these concepts the other thing
about the electrochemical method we hope
to be able to combine that with oriented
orienting the nano wires along desired
directions so we can pick the best
direction which is the trigonal
direction for electrons and whatever
direction I've forgotten for the holes
that will depend on the dopants that
open scheme that we use but that that's
the concept so we could use the
substrate to orient the words but that's
to be demonstrated I'm not sure we'll
succeed
understanding this thermoelectric
application you'd have some sort of an
array of nano wires
yeah yeah for a thermoelectric you know
if you if you're designing a wafer you
have some integrated circuit and you put
this something underneath it the
geometry is what what they would like
they don't really want the geometry to
be planar they like to have the heat
moving away from the plane of the
integrated circuits so this is very this
is desirable and we can make these well
they could be I was thinking more of
replacing my refrigerator but oh your
refrigerator well you just have to have
a lot of these yeah the fairly
wavelength is pretty short because your
effective masses are our smaller family
surfaces are tiny compared to the Berwyn
zone dimensions so your your family
wavelength is is small well you could
arrange it to be either way by I believe
you could you can adjust the design with
with your Fermi level to be in either
limit we haven't worked on that problem
yet but I believe you can do either one
both for N and P type for that matter
yeah well we see we see those kinds of
transitions already the almost all the
work up till now on a sort of classical
size effect have been on three
dimensional limit and this work that we
we've done is the first work in the one
dimensional unit you need to have a
small wired and do the one dimensional
case okay let's no more questions I
think we should thank our speaker
[Applause]